all right let's try something a little
bit different today instead of three
audience questions i'm gonna run through
a few emails i've received over the last
uh week or so really over the last few
days um just respond give my thoughts
this will give us an opportunity to
touch on a bunch of different things and
uh maybe people will like it and
encourage people to send in sort of
thoughtful questions and anecdotes via
email so let's start uh this was a
message i received from john brown john
brown wrote to me about ivermectin
saying hi david my anti-vaccine uncle
told me he has the phone number for a
doctor in florida who will prescribe
ivermectin over the phone i know i know
i try to avoid him but if i get coveted
i'm supposed to call him and he'll call
this quack for a prescription thanks
david best regards john yeah so there's
like three different layers to this
first of all
even the company that makes ivermectin
merck is saying uh this is do not take
take this for covid it doesn't work for
covet it's not approved for covet do not
take this for covet that's number one
number two
uh there are people who are getting this
from veterinarians because typically
in different
solutions
ivermectin is for treating worms in uh
various types of animals uh elements of
animals including
uh heifers and mares and stallions and
this type of thing and then three there
are some doctors who will prescribe it
um and then over the phone is just sort
of like you know on another level right
just sure take it here's a prescription
for ivermectin so i would be uh
extremely careful with that it seems
john has a good head on his shoulders
here and understands that this is not
something you want to be doing the
vaccine the vaccine is now fully fda
approved if what was holding you back
was there was not full fda approval
now there is okay so thanks john for
letting me know about that
tristan wrote to me on sunday
and said dear david i'm on a plane from
rome to new york
and multiple people uh including two
right next to my wife and two across the
way with masks under the mouth or just
off completely just unbelievable we have
no hope thinking it may be time to start
staying home again yeah
i flew back last week as many of you
guys know i flew lufthansa
and there were people all over the place
with no mask now i will commend the
lufthansa flight attendants
because like one one very angry guy
boarded
uh with no mask and complained about
where i had my luggage and was saying no
this is my seat your luggage should be
there and i said dude but we're at the
front of the plane
it's all empty there's room there's so
much room why does why does it matter
where my luggage is
sat down was wearing no mask within 30
seconds a flight attendant came over and
said sir sir did you need me to um give
you a mask and the guy was annoyed and
he said he had been walking quickly
whatever but right away so a lot of it
is it's incumbent upon the flight
attendants if they allow people to not
wear masks people are going to not wear
masks and i totally understand
just saying i'm not going to travel for
the time being but no surprise and you
know my my approach has been
it's it is really annoying to wear a
mask on a plane the entire time i get it
lufthansa in particular they didn't even
let me wear my comfortable mask they
gave me like a surgical one
and the bands behind my ears they're
they're rubbing and they're pulling i
don't like it but right now
if i'm choosing to fly
i'm gonna play by the rules and the
rules are you keep your mask on and so
when they serve food i take it off i eat
and then i put it back on i'm not
playing any mask games
um and that's the least we could uh
expect from people
uh okay a user a viewer named leo
sent me a message regarding jesse
peterson
saying david i'm a 76 year old canadian
living in ontario i happened to fall
upon a youtube clip of you on the jesse
peterson show
how you remain so calm under his barrage
of insane talking points i think he only
has eight puts you up there with saints
you are a brilliant journalist and
communicator never lower yourself to his
level again by being in the same room as
him please sincerely leo yeah i
appreciate that but that that's not my
approach i see those appearances
basically is performance art
um where i'm i'm just not taking it
seriously but i'm pretending to and
there were a few people who saw my
interview with mike pillow mike lindell
of my pillow a couple weeks ago and they
wrote to me and they were sort of upset
i wasn't yelling and screaming at
everything that mike was saying
um and i explained on air that that's
not really how those interviews work
well
it's not these are not people who are
even connected remotely to the real
world they're not gonna see reason so if
i just start arguing at every
opportunity the interview will go
nowhere
and so my approach is to pretend as
though i'm taking it seriously
and just let them kind of
meme themselves
in into into oblivion and that's been my
approach not everybody likes it but that
was my approach with jessie lee
um and i thought it was quite a good
time i have to say i i would actually
appear in his studio again one of the
funniest things and i've told this story
before was
when i went so first of all i don't even
know where to back up and start but so
jessie lee peterson has a studio and
counseling center in la
now
the term counselor is an unregulated
term you're not saying you're a
therapist
where you have do you have a psyd
or an li csw or um
lmhc counselor is sort of like coach
and what he does is it's basically like
a christian ministry coaching type thing
and he i guess has clients that go to
him for help so it's this whole
operation but the funniest part was
the staff on his show at least
not on the on the coaching ministry side
but on the on the show side
they all seem to be pretty big fans of
the david pakman show and a bunch of
them asked for pictures with me and
whatnot so it was actually kind of funny
i don't even know whether they take him
seriously i genuinely have no idea but
it was quite an experience and i would
certainly be willing to appear again
okay also from the email a viewer named
andy wrote to me and said hi david hope
your vacation went well and you enjoyed
your break i was hoping you could update
us on the arizona audit it seems to have
fallen away since all the crazy stuff
that happened in the last 10 days
thanks for your help and always speaking
the truth well nothing is going on with
the audit in the sense that it was never
really an audit um it was effectively
uh it was effectively just a pr thing
and you know at one point they were
looking for bamboo fibers on the ballots
which might be indicative of the ballots
having come from china
they had very powerful lights and heat
which they were going to inject the
ballots with or whatever terminology
they use it's always been a joke it was
never going to do anything so it's not a
surprise that like with many of these
things it just kind of fades away and
then you don't hear about it again now
there may be some follow-up we may hear
some last gasp effort to say something
like oh well somebody
they interfered or they only gave us
copies of the ballots not the originals
and so we weren't able to really do what
we were supposed to do or whatever so we
may hear about it again
but we may not
and a real
sign of cults and cult-like thinking
that's very much like the kind of
apocalypse rapture type christianity
is that the date at which
something will happen keeps getting
pushed and pushed and pushed and that's
what's happening with the trump
reinstatement because remember i mean go
back to election day in november of
2020. it was gonna first it was we won
three days later media says joe biden
won then it becomes by december by safe
harbor day or whatever it was december
14th or something
this will have become trump's win
and then it was by january 6th and then
it was by january 20th and then it was
by march then it was april then it was
august
13th we heard that now it's
by the end of the year
um it's never i mean eventually it'll
just be maybe trump runs runs again and
if you want him to be president you vote
for the guy but it's very very typical
of cult behavior
we've interviewed in fact some of these
apocalyptic people where they say the
rapture is happening on may 5th
and then it doesn't and they say oh yeah
our leader miscalculated and also
mercury was in retrograde and alpha
centauri was five percent less visible
you know who the hell knows what
and now they have a new date it's
typical not surprising whatsoever uh
lastly throwing in just a little bit of
hate mail this is a viewer who has been
writing to me under two names susan and
chris they've probably sent us
i don't know maybe
150 emails over time
and everyone they always use ipads and
susan appeared in my email this week and
said
hey how's that joe joe biden of yours
doing
i'm thinking you're an argentinian
millennial ass
so not very substantive
and that's basically the gist of this
viewer
who writes under two names susan
as well as chris
always the exact same syntax
always sent from ipad they share a last
name
um so that is that
i would be glad and really thrilled to
include your emails in subsequent
segments like this one you can write
into info davidpakman.com and i hope to
include one of your emails soon also
make sure you sign up at joinpacman.com
because we do have the show
and then we have the bonus show and i
would love for you to watch or listen to
the award-winning
world famous bonus show one of many
member benefits when you sign up at
jointpakman.com